as home office representatives arrive
for a parish council meeting in linton
or news residents make clear their
opposition to the plans for an asylum
center
[Applause]
the village population around six or
seven hundred is home to a former raf
base now earmarked to become a
processing centre for up to 1500 asylum
seekers
there's no nimbyism about it at all it
is quite categorically the wrong place
because there's nothing here home office
guidelines state that asylum seekers
should be accommodated in connections
as you can see we're a tiny little rural
village
and
it's not the right place for this type
of
establishment supposed to be a
democratic society but nobody's asked us
and now apparently they're arriving next
week
inside the officials explained a desire
to work with the community but this is a
community that doesn't want to work with
them
stop treating us like in the seals yeah
yeah
from here on in we recognize the fact
that you feel that you haven't been
engaged fully and that we do want to try
and
start that process
the home office says the plans will help
end a reliance on expensive hotels which
is currently costing the taxpayer 4.7
million pounds a day
local conservative mp has also raised
his objections in parliament ukraine it
will devastate the community
it will devastate house prices which
will plummet
and the residents of that village will
not feel safe to leave their homes alone
those who work to help people seek
sanctuary in the uk also have concerns
we know that accommodation centres like
this are extremely harmful for the
people who are placed in them they are
destructive to people's mental health
they end up very isolated and feeling
like they're stuck in in limbo and
separated from the rest of society
[Music]
legal challenges are currently being
considered by both residents and the
district council but with the first
asylum seekers scheduled to arrive at
the end of this month
time is short for those who want to
force the home office to think again
fraser moored sky news linton on news